Girl looking dance like that.
This is what kills me about feminist,
because the minute they see a woman in a position where they are happy,
but it is outside of the traditional hustle grind, boss, babe,
get a career, have a job, etcetera,
they lose their minds.
And I think what's even worse is looking at someone's situation
where they have have said multiple times that they love their life,
the life that they created along with their spouse and their partner.
Y'all think it's abuse? I used to once be a very driven person
with intentions of becoming like
in a lucrative medical based career, okay?
And I chose the housewife life over that.
And people thought I was crazy.
They probably still think I'm crazy and stupid for even choosing that.
It's okay to change what you want in life.
The older you get and the more experiences you have.
You don't have to stay on the single path you've been on.
But part for the quiz,
it's believe all women till you disagree with their lifestyle
and then you use them for clout on the internet.